the saturday's snake continued to weave
in and out of london's landmarks
with no work or school children also
joined the weekend rush
among them martina who still got at
least three hours to go how are your
legs doing um they haven't fallen off
which is very surprising for now
everyone we spoke to is feeling the
strain
but their biggest distraction is
thinking about why they're there
when i get in there it's going to be you
know quite moving and i'll be really
pleased that i've done it actually
it's a journey more than a hundred
thousand have now completed those they
meet along the way ease the pain of
eye-watering hours of walking
but this was the morale boost no one saw
coming
here
you look well you look well good
trainers
the new prince of wales and king thanked
mourners for their time
greeted by a sea of outstretched hands
phones and shocked faces he's doing all
this and at the same time he's grieving
so much
and he's still dedicated to his duties
as well
it was a visit that left henry feeling
both exhausted and exhilarated
it was amazing it made my heart fall out
[Music]
and that's perhaps the biggest surprise
of all after hours of queueing to see
the late monarch her son and her
grandson make time to see them
for those that finally make it inside
westminster hall to pay their respects
outside it's time for yet more goodbyes
farewells to friendships forged on the
cold streets of the capital
11 hours or 12 hours is a long time to
stand there when you're by yourself so i
think we just got on straight away so it
was really nice worth the wait is what
they all say but the finite lying in
state window is fast slipping away
ashanaharanax sky news in central london